to make it big from scratch to make it
happen if everything went down and you
have 29 days to make it happen all right
to get a hundred K is it possible we
have Samuel leads a superstar property
guru a trainer a YouTube maestro on the
house today and if he's gonna be telling
you exactly what he will do
all right so without further ado Samuel
to you do you want to introduce yourself
quickly or anything for that yeah cool
man well thanks so much for having me on
the show great to be here I love your
work and what you're doing on YouTube I
guess I agreed to come on because I love
challenges so the idea of making an
amount of money and an amount of time
just the buzz off the challenge I mean
my background I'm a property investor
I've been property investing for over a
decade now can you believe it and I have
a trading business so I also teach
people what I've been doing that for
about four years and I'm pretty
successful almost successful as a
trainer I'm successful as a property
investor but the thing is there ad you
know this success breeds success so if
you've got you've got a million pounds
and you want to make a second million
it's much easier if you've got a hundred
thousand and you wanna make a second
hundred thousand is much easier than we
start from scratch so you know be
interesting to to brainstorm the best
way to make a hundred thousand pounds
start from scratch it's just a great
discussion great description of
everything yeah you got to be you've got
to be careful because I'll turn this
hypothetical conversation into a reality
I'll just go and do it I could do that
I've done stuff like that before you
know that really appreciate time and we
respect your friendship and then what
you've been doing out there so I just
want people to know that you you are
100% the real deal the reason we're
having this conversation is because
you're going out and consistently
testing what is possible yeah you know
we've done over you know naught to a
million in seven months on an online
funnel for example I think not going to
so 29 days to a hundred thousand is
achievable in many different vehicles
and that's really kind of what this is
all about so go for it what would you
what would you
tomorrow it happens yeah sure so so what
other grammar rules do I still have my
reputation and my following or do I have
absolutely none of that as well would
you like of course I'd love it if I
still had my reputation so let's go from
nothing let's go from nothing so I've
got no reputation no nose you have no
reputation got nothing and I need to
microphone to be the best way so that's
the realist isn't it with your
reputation where you are now but that's
again I could do it in 24 hours so there
you go so so to know that anyone
watching that you can sit like that
that's why business is such a beautiful
thing once you start actually doing it
you see the vehicle working every single
year that you stay in business it gets
easier yeah for you to say that I
totally believe you that you could
you're at a stage where you could do it
in 24 hours with your contact base with
what you've got right now so there's
more that being said let's go to zero
okay so zero um well for a start I think
but if I was starting the game from
scratch now 29 days 300,000 pounds I
would use property as a vehicle now
that's not to say that property is the
best vehicle it's just that that's what
I know and I think that you you you the
way to make money you know find what you
know already find what you're good at if
you're a good marketer if you're a good
property person if you're good with
business or stocks or whatever then then
then do what you're good at one you know
so I do property I take a hundred grand
do I make it cash or can I make it in
equity ia ia if I bought a property if I
bought like a property and I made that
much money in equity or don't actually
need it in my bank let's see if you can
do both yeah I think okay so the soaps
are working backwards
the end goal really is I need to I need
to create one hundred thousand pounds
worth of value to somebody or to a
business so I guess
rephrasing the question is how could I
in 28 days could I add 100,000 pounds
worth of value to somebody and get them
to trust that I can actually do that so
to believe in me okay
I think I'd have to I'd have to just
find a property deal I'd have to go and
find I'd probably go to central London
and I would find I'll be looking at
high-end property investment development
opportunities commercial property in the
millions and I would have to agree on a
heavily discounted price and then I
would go and find a buyer and I would
charge a broker fee and it that broke if
it would have to be a hundred thousand
that just means the deals gotta be juicy
enough let's go back a couple of spaces
so so so so you're basically saying find
find an asset yeah valued asset very
high very high value asset yeah a
top-end uh yeah that you again there's
more margin in that process how do you
then how do you then how would you lock
off that you know you're gonna say that
you're gonna stand for them yeah you
didn't get them a client is that what
you're saying well yeah okay oh I buy
property if someone said to me as an
investor
Samuel we've got a property it's worth
ten million however we've negotiated to
buy it for nine million the ROI is good
is a good deal it's a million pound
better low market value we will let you
have that property but we want a 100,000
pound fee finder's fee I'm paying them a
hundred thousand but I'm saving nine
hundred thousand still so I'll happily
pay the nine hundred I haven't pay the
hundred thousand pounds so what I would
need to do in this situation is I'd need
to become the introducer so I'd need to
find I'd need to be so if I only had
twenty because because because and this
is what this is what I'd have done in
the past but on a smaller scale I found
houses you know residential houses HMOs
blocks of flats and pass them on but the
finder's fee is usually just like five
grand maybe
and grand but I think it would just be a
case of having to rather than messing
around fondant because I could do that I
could just find lots of deals for 5
grand 10 grand and sell them but I think
if you've got to got 28 days I just it
for the challenge because if I get if I
just make 99 thousand pound I fail so
it's not just a case if I want to I want
to make money just because and it rolls
over I gotta make 100 grand it's not an
all-or-nothing thing it would just be a
case of finding a deal that's good
enough that's gonna be worth 100
thousand pounds and then find an
investor sabi sabi doing two things I'll
be warned
I'd be grind in go around mixing with
all the developers go into agents and
I'll be putting offers forward and
trying to find some very attractive
property investments that I could get
below market value and then over here
I'd be going networking and I'll be
looking for in high net worth
individuals or businesses or companies
that are looking to invest in property
and it just be a case of in 28 days
could I find a good enough deal find an
investor and then marry the two together
that'll be my plan solid Doug my plan
and I'm not saying that that's the best
plan would I don't even know for sure if
I'd achieve it because it's quite a big
you know it's quite a big quite big deal
but I've probably could if anyone could
achieve it you're probably me I mean in
essence it's quite simplistic approach
right yeah stop people from from taking
action on that I guess it would probably
just be with that kind of a deal what
would stop people is firstly knowing how
to find a good enough investment
property how to negotiate a deal like
that and then how to find the people
that we're looking videos like that I
he's just everything comes down to
knowledge you know people say money
makes money and although money does make
money to a point
what really makes money is creativity
and the ability to be able to add value
[Music]
[Music]
you